[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE ABRAMS: All right.
Thanks, everyone,
for being here.
For those of you who don't know
me, my name is Mike Abrams.
I'm going to be
moderating today.
We've got three
wonderful guests here.
So to my right, we have
the driver of the 98 car.
You're going to be starting
in the third position.
The defending champion
of the Indy 500 driving
for Andretti Autosport,
Alexander Rossi.
[APPLAUSE]
Next to Alex, we have the
driver of the number four car,
starting in the 26th position.
This is your fourth Indy 500.
Driving for AJ Foyt, Conor Daly.
[APPLAUSE]
And last, but not least, I
could do the introduction,
but I think you
can do it better.
I know you have a historic
way of introducing yourself.
[LAUGHTER]
RIC FLAIR: Hi, I'm Ric Flair.
[APPLAUSE]
Host of the Snake Pit.
MIKE ABRAMS: MCing the
Snake Pit this year.
So let's start with an easy one.
There's a lot of people
here that probably are less
familiar with the Indy 500.
So for all three of
you, what's the 500 mean
to you and the month of May
in Indianapolis, in general?
CONOR DALY: I'll go first.
Well, the 500, for
me, is my home race.
Born and raised in Indy, so
I love it for that reason.
It's always been sort of the
Super Bowl, the World Series,
everything combined, for me.
It's just the biggest
thing that we have.
And it's a month
long, so it's awesome.
I love it.
Would mean the most to win
that for me, as for any driver,
I think.
But yeah, just an amazing event.
And if you haven't
been, for sure,
I'd say give it
a chance some day
because it will surprise you.
MIKE ABRAMS: Alex,
what about you?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Yeah.
Like Conor said, I mean,
it's the biggest, not only
race in the world, but
biggest single-day sporting
event in the world, as well.
So it's a pretty
special experience
and as a racing driver, it's
one of the three main events
that you want to win.
So a lot of effort goes
into it from all of us,
from all of the teams,
and it all comes to a head
here in a couple of days.
MIKE ABRAMS: Now, Ric,
will this be your first 500
or have you been before?
RIC FLAIR: This will
be my first 500,
but actually, Indianapolis
is where I was--
my first WrestleMania,
WrestleMania VIII,
against Randy Savage.
So I've always been a fan of
Indy and Peyton and Larry Bird.
And it's a great sport city.
And it's not that I
couldn't have gone, I just--
probably, my schedule
didn't allow it.
But I'm really
looking forward to it
and when I heard my-- when this
opportunity became available,
I just said, god,
please figure me in.
And then I've had a great time
today with these gentlemen.
And they're the
most courageous--
they are the most
courageous athletes alive.
And no, I'm not going for a
ride with Marco Andretti, OK?
Sorry.
Don't even suggest it, please.
CONOR DALY: You
got to do it, man.
You got to do it.
RIC FLAIR: Nada, nada.
I'll have a heart attack
and he'll have one, too.
That'd be all we need.
Where's the needs?
Upside down.
MIKE ABRAMS: Conor,
you mentioned
you're an Indiana native.
So what's the entire month
of May like in Indiana
from before you were
a driver to now,
as you are racing in the 500?
CONOR DALY: It's always
our biggest thing.
Even downtown Indianapolis, they
put all the drivers' last names
on street signs all
around the city.
So it's one of those things
where there's billboards
everywhere, there
are signs everywhere.
It's our biggest
event by a long way.
You know, even when
we had the Super Bowl,
the Indy 500 still just
blows it out of the water,
just for sheer
magnitude and the amount
of people that are there.
Just even over the
weekend in qualifying,
last weekend in qualifying,
thousands of people there.
We have Carb Day
coming up on Friday.
100,000 people there.
Race day, obviously, over
300,000, 350,000 people there.
So it's just massive.
And the city really embraces
it, which is really cool.
And it makes us feel
special, as well.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Alex, I know
you were a big football fan.
What got you into
racing at a young age?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: My father.
He was just a motor sports fan.
He went to races with his father
and when I was 10 years old,
he took me to Las
Vegas for reasons
that most people
don't go to Las Vegas.
But it was to do a
three-day go-cart school.
And it was supposed to be a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
And I fell in love
with the sport
and started racing go karts
and here we are at Google.
So right on.
MIKE ABRAMS: And Conor, your
dad was a professional driver.
So was there ever any
doubt in your mind
that you were going to
go into race driving?
CONOR DALY: I guess not.
Yeah, he was-- he did
some stuff in race cars
and then moved to Indiana.
And then--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: What did he do?
CONOR DALY: He just circulated.
He circulated for many times.
And he met my mom when he
came to do the Indy 500
and he never left.
So that was-- and then I came
to be and then he stopped racing
and, sadly, I got
into it and I think
he was forced to
stay in it himself.
So it's just a
family thing for us.
We love it.
He loves it still.
I love it.
Very lucky to be doing it.
I mean, there's
not a lot of people
who can really, really live
their dream and, you know,
that's what I'm
doing, so it's cool.
MIKE ABRAMS: And
Ric, you're widely
regarded as the greatest
professional wrestler
of all time.
So--
[CHEERS]
RIC FLAIR: Thank you.
MIKE ABRAMS: And
a Hall of Famer.
So what's--
RIC FLAIR: I'm glad you
didn't say, one of, OK?
MIKE ABRAMS: The,
the, the greatest.
RIC FLAIR: I'm just kidding.
MIKE ABRAMS: You know,
what's exciting you
most about being part of
the festivities of the 500?
RIC FLAIR: Well,
I was just going
to ask these guys because
I'm thinking about it.
When we have WrestleMania,
you know, the 500
is our WrestleMania.
And we bring--
I know, when we go to--
we just came out of Orlando and
we brought, like, $50 million
worth of money, maybe $60
million, into the community.
And I'm just thinking to
myself, how much money
comes along with the race?
And I'm not talking about
prize money for the driver.
I'm talking about the economy.
I'm sure every
hotel is sold out.
I better find out
where I'm staying now.
And it's not going
to be the courtyard.
Don't do courtyards or taxis.
But I'm just thinking, my god,
it's got to be overwhelming.
And Indianapolis is such
a great city, my god.
Great bars, great night
life, nice people.
Indiana is a good state, period.
CONOR DALY: Thank you.
Appreciate that.
RIC FLAIR: No, it's the truth.
CONOR DALY: I like it, too.
RIC FLAIR: We got to work on
the Indiana basketball team.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, we do.
We do.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALEXANDER ROSSI: I mean,
the football team's
not great, either, is it?
Let's be honest.
MIKE ABRAMS: All right.
Let's change subjects.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: You're
from Indiana, aren't you?
MIKE ABRAMS: I am from Indiana.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: So that
doesn't feel good, does it?
MIKE ABRAMS: So let's talk
about last year's race,
the 100th running.
It was a historic race.
Conor, can you speak to what
leading up to the 100th running
was like, and all the hype
around this monumental race?
CONOR DALY: Well, it was
cool, that's for sure.
And I guess he enjoyed
it a little bit more
than the rest of us.
But yeah, I mean, the 100th
was cool to be a part of that.
I mean, there's not
many events that
are in their 100th
running, so it
was really cool to just
be a part of history,
start the next 100 years.
You know, obviously now,
this year with the 101st.
So incredible what the
city did, as he was saying.
The state of Indiana,
you know, it's
huge for Indiana, the economy,
the people, everything.
So it was awesome for us.
We sold it out, which is--
I mean, that's a lot of people.
So it was really cool.
And then a young American
gentleman was the winner,
so that helped for just America.
And that was good.
So I liked that.
I mean, I had a horrible
time, but that doesn't matter.
MIKE ABRAMS: Well, Alex,
let's talk about your victory.
You won using a fairly
bold fuel strategy.
What was going through your
mind, went into the decision,
knowing that you
were running out
of fuel in the last few laps?
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
Well, we really didn't
have a choice because
of some scenarios
that happened during the race.
We had to go off
sequence to everyone else
and it put us in
a position to be
in some pretty severe
fuel-saving at the end,
to the point where I actually
ran out of fuel on the last lap
and the engine was off and
I coasted across the line.
So I don't necessarily want to
have to go through that again
because it was pretty chaotic
for everyone involved.
But when you're
in the car, you're
just focused on the
job you need to do
and you take it
one lap at a time.
I mean, everyone in their
respective professions,
when you get involved in
something, it's kind of--
it's a subconscious
thing that happens.
So it's the same thing
for us and you just
try and execute and maximize
everything that you have.
MIKE ABRAMS: And as
defending champion,
you've gotten to do some
pretty cool experiences,
shooting at an intermission
at a Blackhawks game,
throwing out the first--
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
It's not that cool.
MIKE ABRAMS: Throwing out the
first pitch of the Cubs game.
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
Also not that cool.
MIKE ABRAMS: What's been
your favorite thing you've
done as defending champion,
non-racing related?
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
Well, this, obviously.
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, you think about Google
as like this one page of stuff.
You don't think of it as
this entire city block,
so it's pretty cool to be
here and it's pretty awesome.
CONOR DALY: I just think of
"The Internship," the movie.
That's my favorite movie.
I love it.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: He's-- yeah.
Anyway, for me, the highlight
was the SBs in June.
And it was because I got to--
I mean, I got to meet Cam
Newton, LeBron, Kobe, I mean,
sports idols and icons, right?
Which is pretty spectacular.
And to share an
evening with them,
honoring their kind of
success over the year
was pretty special.
RIC FLAIR: Are you a LeBron man?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Oh, yeah.
RIC FLAIR: All right, man.
Me, too.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: He's
the king, isn't he?
RIC FLAIR: I had to
tell the commissioner--
I had to give him
the heads-up, man.
How he's not the
MVP over and over.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Last game
wasn't great, though, for him,
was it?
18 points.
RIC FLAIR: Yeah.
But that's OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALEXANDER ROSSI: We'll
be all right, yeah.
RIC FLAIR: I wouldn't
want to be there tonight.
I mean, I wanted to be, but--
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
You're here with us.
RIC FLAIR: --thing about that,
I can't go to LeBron tonight
because I'm here today.
Can't make the flight, so.
But I'm glad to be here.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to be on the
good side of Google.
God only knows they've
exhausted me a couple times.
I just Googled you.
OK, really?
That's nice.
Does that really happen?
No.
CONOR DALY: Allegedly.
RIC FLAIR: Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: So
let's change gears
to talk about the Snake Pit.
Conor, being the
Indiana native, I'll
let you-- for everyone
that's not familiar with it,
can you kind of give an
explanation of what it is
and how it's evolved
the last few years.
CONOR DALY: Absolutely.
The Snake Pit was big
in the '70s, I believe.
I wasn't alive at
that time, but they
used to, like, burn couches and
have crazy stuff go on there.
Obviously, a drinking festival.
But there was also the Indy
500 going on at the same time.
And it sort of went away-ish.
I think people discovered--
to be more civilized.
But then, now, we're
bringing it back, obviously,
because it's all about a
good EDM rave these days.
And so now, the last
few years, we've
had incredible electronic music
artists playing from 8:00 AM
to 3:00 PM in the afternoon.
It's like our own music
festival inside of turn three.
We fit 30,000, 40,000
people inside of turn three
and there's still
a race going on.
And there's still
239,000 permanent seats
sold out for the race.
And a lot of people
don't even know
that there's a race going on
if they're in the Snake Pit
because, obviously,
they're upside-down wasted,
but it's a great time,
from what I've heard.
RIC FLAIR: Hate that, hate that.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, right?
And Ric's going to
be there and he's
going to be hooting
and hollering.
And--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: But you'll
be there, as well, won't you?
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
Ric's going to be the MC.
I'm going to be there
for 28 minutes, I think,
and that's all I can do.
From like, 9:45 to
about 10:15-ish.
But I love that music.
We've got Zed, Marshmallow,
RL Grime, Adventure Club,
and Action Bronson
playing this year.
So that should be
a decent lineup.
And yeah, it's
changed massively,
but it's really cool.
I mean, it's an
actual music festival,
which is something we don't
have in Indiana at all.
But going on right in the center
of the massive race, as well.
So it's incredible and I think
Ric's going to really enjoy it.
He's going to be the
leader of it all.
We need a good leader
in the Snake Pit.
RIC FLAIR: I'm
certainly going to try.
Woo.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm looking forward to--
because I didn't realize
that both these gentlemen are
single and they live together.
If my fiance will let me,
I'm going to the after party.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Can
we clarify the live--
yeah.
RIC FLAIR: Well, you
guys share a mansion.
CONOR DALY: No.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: No.
[LAUGHTER]
CONOR DALY: If I mansion
is-- how many square footage
is that?
17?
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
He rents a room.
CONOR DALY: I rent
a room at his house.
RIC FLAIR: OK.
CONOR DALY: That's what I do.
RIC FLAIR: What I was saying--
CONOR DALY: But I'm single
and I'm ready to party, yeah.
RIC FLAIR: I wanted--
are you married?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: No.
RIC FLAIR: Oh, I
didn't think so.
I want to go to the after party.
Are you kidding?
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
Well, hey, the plan is for
you to recruit for the after
party in the Snake Pit.
RIC FLAIR: Well, I can do that.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
My man.
RIC FLAIR: [WHISTLES] Hey, you.
[APPLAUSE]
CONOR DALY: There we go.
Now the after party is
going to be really good.
RIC FLAIR: Give me some keys
and I'll just pass them out.
[APPLAUSE]
CONOR DALY: 15, yeah.
15 room keys.
RIC FLAIR: I'll
cover you, brother.
Don't worry about that.
I know how to throw a party.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Ric, you are
hosting the Snake Pit party.
Do you have anything
special planned for it?
RIC FLAIR: No, I'm just excited.
I didn't realize--
never having gone,
I didn't even know
what the Snake Pit was.
I'm just a big fan of
the Indianapolis race.
I'm from NASCAR Country,
but to me, it's just totally
two different things.
And like I said, our
NASCAR guys are--
they drive fast and
hard, too, but there's
a lot more protection.
You know, especially
since Dale got killed,
they got the helmets and
they're locked in pretty good.
But these guys, man, 230 miles
an hour in an open cockpit.
I mean, jeez.
I've been in an F-16
and I didn't like that.
But it's amazing.
I'm just really
looking forward to it
and enjoying the experience.
And my fiance-- you forgot Keith
Urban is going to be there.
She is flipped already.
Yes, I'm going to get
you backstage, OK?
CONOR DALY: It's a
party the whole weekend.
Keith Urban's there Saturday.
RIC FLAIR: Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: So
Alex and Conor, I
know you guys are going
230 miles an hour,
but do you feel a
different energy
when you come around turn
three and fly by that party?
CONOR DALY: Absolutely.
It smells a little
different, but yeah.
No, don't you remember that?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: What
energy do you have coming--
CONOR DALY: I love it.
I just-- because I know
what's going on there
and I'm excited about it.
You guys might think
differently, but I love it.
I love it.
You can't really see it.
You can see-- it's hard to--
when we're racing,
we don't see anything
except for what's going
on around us, obviously.
That sounded terrible.
But it's on the pace
lap, when you leave
the grid for the first lap.
That's when you--
and you're going
just-- we're doing 100 miles
an hour as our pace car speed.
And we're just like-- but
100 is really slow for us,
so we're inching along
and you see the people.
I think that's the
most incredible thing.
You just see this entire
facility just full.
I mean, what did you think?
That That was your first
one, so was that surprising?
Did you like that?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Yeah.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, see?
It was awesome.
MIKE ABRAMS: And Conor, you
made a surprise visit last year
in full suit and helmet--
CONOR DALY: Yes.
MIKE ABRAMS: --to the Snake Pit.
CONOR DALY: I did.
MIKE ABRAMS: How was that and
were you the only person fully
clothed at that point?
CONOR DALY: Yes.
I had three layers
of fireproof clothing
on at an 80-degree event,
rave, crazy day party.
I went up into the
crowd and people started
spraying me with cheap beer.
And I was covered in
Bush Light by the time
I got back to my strategy
meeting for the race.
But it was awesome.
It was so cool.
And I will be there again
and I might wear a poncho
this time though.
It's frowned upon to show
up to a motor race smelling
of alcohol, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was a great time.
MIKE ABRAMS: So let's switch
gears to this year's race.
Let's talk a little bit
about qualifications.
You guys had some
challenging weather
limiting the opportunities.
Alex, you had a pretty rough day
one by having to sit in the car
while they cleaned up
the track after a wreck.
What goes through your mind
as you're sitting there,
I think, unknown
what's going on,
and you only have one
attempt on that day?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: The main
thing is just making sure
that Sebastian was OK.
And that's where all
your attention goes,
so you don't really care about
anything else at that point.
Because all of us
are competitors,
but very close at the same time.
So it was a really
big hit and when
you see that, you
don't really quite know
what the immediate outcome is.
So once you find out
he's OK, then you
just go through your
routine, your process,
and you go out and do
what you need to do.
MIKE ABRAMS: Day two, you
guys had some better weather,
but you still didn't have
as much practice time
as you probably wanted.
How do you guys make
adjustments on the fly
with really, again,
one attempt to qualify
with limited practice?
CONOR DALY: It's
really difficult
because to go out
there and really push
these cars at the limit--
I mean, he was going a little
quicker than I was at 231.
But we qualified at 226.5
and that still felt--
that was a really
difficult run for me
because we haven't really
been able to get our car very
comfortable the whole time.
And when you're doing that
speed, you feel everything.
You feel everything in the car.
If you have one moment, you
end up in bad shape really,
really quickly.
So it's challenging, but in the
end, it's qualifying for Indy
and you know, for
four laps, you have
to go out there and
eliminate every emotion,
every thought other than
doing the best four laps
that you can because
it is very important.
The race is obviously
what we all care about,
but qualifying is also--
the further up the grid
you start, the better.
But it's one of those
things that, in the end,
the race is all that matters.
But qualifying, I think
just from a history
standpoint at the
Indy 500, is always
very cool and very important.
MIKE ABRAMS: So speaking a
little bit about the history,
you guys both drive for
teams with Indy 500 legends.
Conor, you with AJ, and then
Alex, you with the Andrettis.
What's it like, as
they help you prepare,
to have that much history
and that much knowledge
on your team?
And then what's it also like
just having a famous boss,
celebrities around the track?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Yeah.
Driving for Michael is
a pretty huge privilege
and I was very fortunate,
as a rookie last year,
to come in and have that
amount of depth and knowledge
to rely upon.
And not only did I
have Michael and Mario,
but my car was actually a
part of another team, which
was owned by another
driver named Bryan Herta.
And they merged with Andretti
and so I had Brian, as well.
And that's just a wealth of
information and knowledge
to sponge off of them.
And they're very successful
and, you know, my teammates,
as well.
Marco Andretti and
Ryan Hunter-Reay
are hugely successful at the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway.
So I had a lot of very
helpful people around me
and it was great.
And Michael is a very,
very cool guy to work for.
CONOR DALY: And AJ is just
an old school American hero.
He's still shouting and cursing
and wishing he was still
in the car at 82 years old.
But he's awesome.
He's still passionate about it.
He still wants to win, even
though he's not in the car.
But we're trying
our best for him
because it'd be cool to get
him back to victory lane.
Because he's just a badass
dude, so that's awesome.
MIKE ABRAMS: So there's a lot
of ways to win the Indy 500,
also a lot of ways to lose it.
And I think, for the
novice fans out here,
there's probably not a
true understanding of all
the technology, to teammates,
to everything in between that
goes into winning.
What goes into having a good
winning strategy for the 500?
CONOR DALY: Fuel
strategy, right, Alex?
[LAUGHTER]
ALEXANDER ROSSI: That's
one of the ways, yeah.
I mean, a lot.
Let's take Andretti
Autosport for example.
There's 200 people that
work on the program.
So it's a very big operation.
You have everything from your
normal day-to-day mechanics,
engineers, to sim engineers to
guys who are in the wind tunnel
and shaker rig.
And it's a big program
to run race cars.
And as much as it appears
to be an individual sport,
with the drivers getting
most of the attention,
it's probably one of the biggest
teams sports in the world
because you can--
it doesn't matter how good of
a race car driver you are--
and Conor can probably
talk to this a little bit.
But if you don't have
the equipment to win,
there's nothing you
can do about it.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, it's tough.
The strategy is to win
any way you can, right?
So there's multiple
ways to do it.
Some obviously, he has 200
people on their team working.
We have about 25
on our two cars.
So it's a little different.
But they're still-- we
all still go out and race
and compete against each
other at a very high level.
But it's a challenging sport.
There are a lot of
really incredible talents
that we race against and
a lot of really good teams
with a lot of really
good, smart engineers.
So it's tough no matter what,
but that's why we do it.
That's why we compete.
MIKE ABRAMS: Since we
are here at Google,
talk to us a little
bit about the data
that you guys accumulate
during practice rounds
and the engineers that
help you to formulate
your strategy on race day.
CONOR DALY: Data is everything.
We have sensors on
every part of the car.
It's streaming live
to the pit stands
so our engineers can look at it.
It's very important
for us, as well,
especially at the Indy
500 because everything
is so crucial.
The thousandth of every--
you know, every degree,
every temperature of
the tire, every sensor,
all the arrow data that we
see, supremely important.
So we rely on technology
a lot and it's
one of those things
that is always evolving.
So it's cool to
see the next level
of what we get every year.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: The
hardest thing, I think,
is correlating real-life
data to sim data.
Because the speedway
is all about finding
the balance between downforce
and drag and how much grip
you want to take away
from the car to go quicker
in a straight line.
There's a lot of different
aerodynamic builds
that you can have with
different packages of components
and parts.
And wind tunnel and sim data
often gives you a direction,
but there's quite a few
times where it's wrong,
and so you're trying
to spend a lot of time
correlating it back to reality.
And that's where a lot of the
differences are made, I think,
at Indianapolis,
specifically, among teams.
You're measuring that with
everything from load cells
to pitot tubes to strain gauges.
It's a lot of very,
very involved things
that is fascinating
to be a part of
and cool to work with every day.
MIKE ABRAMS: So the
million-dollar question,
how are the cars running
for the 101st running?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Sweet.
I'm pretty happy.
CONOR DALY: Less
than ideal, but I
got a positive outlook on life,
so the glass is half full,
guys.
It's going to be a great time.
We're coming from the back.
It's going to be a great story.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's what
I'm excited about.
Ric's going to be there in
victory lane with the milk
and we're going to
have a great time.
So yeah, I'm excited about that.
You going to drink the
milk with me if we win?
RIC FLAIR: Yeah.
And I'm going to
kiss the bricks, too.
CONOR DALY: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
RIC FLAIR: I'll
be doing all that.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
I love it.
MIKE ABRAMS: And Ric,
you have a "30 for 30"
coming out this year.
RIC FLAIR: Yes.
MIKE ABRAMS: Is
there anything that's
going to surprise people?
RIC FLAIR: I'm worried
a lot of people
are going to think
that it's fantasy.
I've led a pretty
interesting life,
as you can google and see.
But yeah, I'm real
excited about it.
It's going to be almost
two hours, I think.
It comes out September
8, so I'm excited.
It's been two years
in the making.
There's a lot of people involved
in it, so I'm excited about it.
You know, there's
obviously-- it discusses
some ups and lows, which
everybody, unfortunately,
experiences in life.
You're too young to have ever
experienced anything like that.
But you know, there's good
things and bad things.
But I think, for
the most part, I'm
excited because I'm the
first wrestler they've ever
done anything like that with.
And everybody I know--
I'm very close to
Evander Holyfield.
Anybody that's done a "30 for
30" has raised their incomes
dream major on the weekends for
speaking engagements and stuff
like that.
So bring it, baby.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I got four ex-wives.
I'm the only guy
allowed to pay alimony
to three women at one time.
Yep.
And I'm still humping, guys.
By that, I meant humping
the road, working.
Working, I meant.
Excuse me.
Yeah, excuse me.
So yeah.
CONOR DALY: My hero right here.
RIC FLAIR: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm really--
MIKE ABRAMS: So on
that note, we're
going to open up the
audience questions.
[LAUGHTER]
There is a mic over here and
while people are lining up
for questions, I had a couple of
fun ones that we wanted to ask.
So for Alex and Conor,
if you were a wrestler,
what would your
wrestling name be
and what would
your go-to move be?
CONOR DALY: Randy Cool.
I think that's what my name--
that's actually my name.
My engineer gave
it to me last year.
MIKE ABRAMS: Randy Cool?
CONOR DALY: Because
it's my name just with--
what is that, an anagram?
Is that where your different
letters, or you can create
words?
I don't know.
I didn't go to college.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Don't
use words you don't know.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
I didn't get--
RIC FLAIR: Well, for now
on, you're Randy Cool to me
for sure.
I like-- that's a cool name.
CONOR DALY: There you go, see?
RIC FLAIR: Hey, Randy Cool.
Hey, sweetheart,
come meet Randy Cool.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Are you
saying Ric Flair is not
your real name?
CONOR DALY: Oh, man.
RIC FLAIR: Ric Flair?
It's not my real name.
I never changed it, legally.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Who
would've thought?
RIC FLAIR: But
you call me Slick.
My friends call me "Nay-tch."
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
Nature boy right here.
MIKE ABRAMS: And Ric,
for Alex and Conor,
can you do one of your
patented hype videos
for them for the
101st running so they
have something to think about
right when they get in the car?
RIC FLAIR: Oh, yeah.
Hey, boys.
Hype for Alexander
Rossi and Conor Daly.
This Sunday, the
Indianapolis 500, man.
We'll be limousine riding,
we'll be jet flying,
we'll be kiss stealing,
we'll be wheel and dealing
and you guys will be going 200
miles an hour on the track.
And I'll be going, woo!
[APPLAUSE]
And to the winner go the
spoils and then Them the event,
damn race is over, we are going
to party with these gentlemen
right here, Alexander and
Conor, all night long.
Woo!
Don't be afraid to live
the legend, ladies.
Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
And if you win the
race, on of you guys,
you guys are buying a drink.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, absolutely.
RIC FLAIR: I'm not picking
up the tab that night.
CONOR DALY: I am motivated.
That was amazing.
RIC FLAIR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
so much, you guys,
for coming out and
speaking to us.
Really appreciate it.
Very cool experience.
So my dad is a huge car
fan and also actually got
to spend some time with
some of the pro wrestlers
back in the down circuit
doing some philanthropic work
and had nothing but great
things to say about them.
So I grew up spending some
time watching cars go round
and wrestling, as well.
I just want to know,
what's the experience
like being able not only
to live out your dream,
but also continue to see
your sports evolve and get
a new fanbase?
And where do you see the
general health of both sports
right now?
RIC FLAIR: Well, first
of all, I think it's--
what I'm happy
about is that I've
been able, through four
decades, to track what I call
a cross-demographic
appeal, where now,
I'm actually making friends
that are in the IndyCar drivers
that I've never had an
opportunity to do before.
And the baseball players,
I interact with them a lot.
And Sergio Brown, who was
the Colts, put me on the map
with the "keeping the
alligators "down thing.
So I've just had a lot
of fun and it's just
another experience for me.
The state of
wrestling right now,
it's different than
what I did for a living.
But my daughter is
in it, she loves it.
And WWE is a fabulous
place to work.
The kids-- they work hard,
but they make a lot of money
and they put a lot more
time and consideration
into their well-being.
The health, the
concussion stuff,
and that now because
of all the injuries.
It's choreographed, but
it's a rough physical sport.
And we had five guys with broken
necks in the last three years.
So it's tough, but
to me, it wouldn't
be nearly as tough
as driving a car
to 220 or 230 miles an hour.
I just think-- I don't get that.
But I'm honored that I'm in
the presence of two guys that
do that for a living.
And spending the whole day
with Conor, which I have,
he thrives on it.
So it's nice to wake
up and be that excited.
I was very excited about
wrestling every day, too.
But I wasn't driving 220 miles
an hour to get to the building.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, we drove
a little slower to get here.
I obviously love doing what I
do, so very lucky to do that.
As for the health
of our sport, I
think it needs some
help still, obviously.
We had-- after the split and
when we got reunited back
in '08, '09, I always said
it would probably be 10 years
before we'd really start
to pick up traction again,
as one open-wheel racing series,
which next year would be 10
years since the split.
So I think we got
a lot of momentum
last year through
the 100th running.
I think we've had
really great racing.
Our product is not the problem.
It's just a lot of
things to try and get it
onto people's televisions,
you know what I mean?
TV ratings are king
right now, so that's
very important for us.
But I think this
year, as well, we
have Fernando Alonso
competing in the Indy
500, which is massive for
the sport, in general.
And our races just
keep getting better.
We have some incredible races
and I think that's good for us.
We're just-- I think
we're on the up and up.
We're technically the
only form of racing
that's actually going
in an upward trend
when it comes to ratings
and stuff like that,
so that's nice.
RIC FLAIR: Do you think
that Ashley Judd will ask me
for my autograph?
CONOR DALY: Oh, she's
not around anymore.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: She's
definitely not around.
CONOR DALY: She got divorced.
RIC FLAIR: I'm not going then.
She got divorced?
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
RIC FLAIR: Did she really?
CONOR DALY: She's not
with Dario anymore.
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
She's single, though.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
She might be there, though.
RIC FLAIR: Just kidding.
I stood next to Brooke
Shields one night at the Ritz
here in New York, and
I'm a big fan, right?
I was this close
to her, like this.
Close as you and I are
for an hour, right?
And she never looked
at me one time, never
said nothing, right?
CONOR DALY: That's the worst.
RIC FLAIR: So the
guy goes to me--
that's with the
company-- he goes,
maybe she doesn't
watch wrestling.
I said, watch wrestling?
I'm Ric Flair.
What the hell?
And she still hasn't
said hi to me yet.
CONOR DALY: That's the
way most girls do--
RIC FLAIR: I know.
CONOR DALY: --with me, too.
RIC FLAIR: She just ignored me.
Kept turning her back to me.
CONOR DALY: Same.
That happens all the time.
Meanwhile, our boy there from--
all the guys love me,
but Brooke, not so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
all for being here.
My question is for Ric Flair.
What was your favorite
match that you were
in at Madison Square Garden?
RIC FLAIR: Gosh, you
want to know something?
I tell people this.
I was never--
I'm from the south, right?
And I really enjoyed,
obviously, working for WWE.
But I don't think I
was ever a big card.
Does that make sense?
First of all, I was older
when I got to wrestle
a little more frequently.
But probably the
best match I ever
had was back in the '90s
when I wrestled Hulk
for the first time that.
It was like, man, we call
him the Golden Goose.
I have only wrestled a
few people in my life
that were over with
the public like Hulk.
And you know, he was selling
vitamins and drinking milk
and I was chasing women and
drinking beer, you know?
It's magic.
The perfect bad guy and
the perfect good guy.
But man, wherever we went,
we sold out everywhere.
It was amazing.
All over the world.
I wrestled him in
Tokyo and we sold out.
So it's been a great experience.
He's a phenomenal guy.
He's been through
a lot, personally.
Not just, as we
know with one issue,
but health-wise, he's
had seven back operations
and he's in a lot of pain.
So I talk to him all the time.
He's doing much better.
He's in good shape,
financially, and I just
wish the best for him.
Wrestling him in the Garden
was something special.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
I'm an Indiana native, too.
CONOR DALY: Sweet.
AUDIENCE: I'm glad
you guys came out.
Yeah.
So first, I had the original Ric
Flair doll, the action figure.
He's the only one that ever
beat Optimus Prime in a fight.
[LAUGHTER]
RIC FLAIR: What did he say?
CONOR DALY: You
were the only one
to beat Optimus
Prime in a fight--
RIC FLAIR: Oh, yeah.
CONOR DALY: --with the doll.
AUDIENCE: But just given the
change of how media is, do you
have anything you would offer
these guys from the days
pre-internet, when you
got famous before YouTube,
to propel them, advice-wise?
RIC FLAIR: These gentlemen here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RIC FLAIR: Well, first of all,
I think it's just in their,
the little bit that I know them.
But they're obviously raised
by great parents and I
don't think that they are--
they're never going to be put
into situations where I failed.
I could have never--
if this was the '80s, I wouldn't
be allowed on the street,
much less--
we pretty much did what we
wanted back then, you know?
Anything I said on TV,
I was pretty much doing.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
See you at the Marriott tonight,
18 to 28, no boyfriends,
no husbands, come on.
[LAUGHTER]
Kind of like you're
gonna do in the race, OK?
I'll handle the after-party.
CONOR DALY: Oh, gee, I hope so.
Wow.
RIC FLAIR: But no, it
just would have killed me.
I'm on a very short
leash with my fiance.
You notice she's right here.
I'm not allowed out of sight.
Come here.
[WHISTLES]
And why did you ask
her if she was married?
I don't know I asked
her, it's just normal.
[LAUGHTER]
Not going to happen again.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of questions.
For Alexander first, I know
you have Formula 1 Experience
and I'm just curious to know
how you think that that played
into your victory last year,
if you learned anything
that you brought with you.
And the other is, I'm curious to
get your takes on Team Penske's
performance over the weekend
because it's wasn't fabulous.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Look
who's paying attention.
Right on.
All right.
So first question is,
Formula 1 is the pinnacle
of motor sports in Europe.
IndyCar is the pinnacle
of motor sports in the US.
And I think that any of the top
drivers in either championship
that go to the other
will be successful
because to win in
IndyCar, you have
to have an innate level of skill
and talent and competitiveness.
Same in Formula 1.
So there's a lot of--
I think that any of the guys
can drive either of the cars.
There's actually
not much crossover,
in terms of technique, but
just the general understanding
of how to extract
performance from a car
will remain the same no
matter what you drive,
whether it's a
Honda Civic in town
or a Formula 1 car
and an IndyCar.
So I think that it wasn't
necessarily just Formula 1
experience, it was just
motor sports experience
that gave me that opportunity.
And then, in terms of
Penske, my engineer actually
used to work for Ed
Carpenter Racing, who
was the only Chevy that
was really competitive.
And he looks at their aero
configuration and is just like,
they're completely wrong.
Not even remotely
close to being correct.
So it's very interesting
because they obviously
have a huge amount of resources
and have been very successful
there and have all the time in
the wind tunnel that they need.
But it was kind of what
I touched on earlier.
Their correlation
to real-life data
clearly isn't
matching up very well
and they literally are
just taking away downforce
to add drag, and it's just
the last thing you want to do,
which is why we seem
them out of the top 20.
So it's very strange, but
I'm not complaining about it
because it's five less cars
that I have to race against.
And yeah.
CONOR DALY: Well,
we'll see on Sunday.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't drive for
Team Penske, clearly,
but what he's saying when
it comes to aerodynamics
is it really is interesting.
Because the Chevrolet package
is struggling, for sure.
But you wouldn't expect
Penske to be struggling.
And then, as he said, the
Ed Carpenter racing cars
nearly had the pull.
I mean, they won
[INAUDIBLE] second.
And that blows my mind,
as well, because we were--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: We
have consistently.
CONOR DALY: We were running--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Like
Joseph was last year.
CONOR DALY: I know that,
which was incredible.
And we were running, literally,
almost exactly the same topside
downforce as they
were, but we were going
like four mile an hour slower.
So they're doing something
really good, the Carpenter
cars.
And then Roger, I
think, is probably
frustrated with their
whole program right now.
But I mean, it's Penske, so
it's the Indy 500 and Penske.
No matter where
they start, they're
going to be probably up at
the front, at some point,
I would have to say.
At least one or two of
them, without a doubt.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Yeah.
I mean, Will was quick.
CONOR DALY: Will was fast, yeah.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Right.
CONOR DALY: But
even like, I think--
I mean Joseph, obviously,
qualified second last year,
so he knows what he's
doing around there.
And Helio is going
for four, as usual,
so we'll see what happens.
He's brave, too.
He's been running
the two-tire ramps.
I don't know if
you've been watching.
But yeah, there's
some pieces on our car
that can make the car
handling very, very sketchy,
but it'll go fast
in a straight line.
And Helio's been
the master of those.
He hasn't crashed
yet, so that's good.
AUDIENCE: Once again,
thanks a lot for all three
of you coming out.
Really appreciate it.
I was curious, as
drivers, how much
of the technology
of the car do you
need to be aware of in
order to race competitively?
And then, related
to that, how much
does it change year to year?
How much is the
technology evolving?
How quickly is it evolving?
CONOR DALY: Well, I guess,
we stay within a certain set
of regulations.
So I think the technology
level, we kind of have--
we use we use things for
different year periods,
whether it's three years
with a certain type of ECU
or something before we get--
I think next year, we
all get better ECU.
Whenever the new
engine comes, we just
get the next level of
ECU and stuff like that.
So the technology, it
depends on how much money
you have to spend.
There's always more--
the more money,
the more things you can
do, or the more development
you can do.
And the more-- simulation is
obviously massive right now,
as Alex said.
That's one of the
things that teams
are using a lot
because of the fact
that it costs you know
$30,000 to $35,000, $40,000
to do a test day with
your actual race car.
Doesn't cost that much to
just jump in a simulator
to do some testing.
And if you can get
accurate data from that,
then it sort of eliminates
the cost of real-life testing,
although for us, real-life
testing is way better.
But yeah, it's an
ever-changing game.
And for us, there's always
new things to learn,
I think more so in
Formula One, there's
always a lot more new things.
But they also have half a
billion dollars to spend.
And we're on, like, $8
million budgets for the year.
So it's one of those things
that's a little different.
But your team has a lot
more technology than mine,
so I don't know if you
have anything to add.
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
Oh, hi, you're here.
Hi.
The driver understanding
of it is very important
because say, for example, you
have a car that you're not
happy with the entry of it.
The engineer will be
like, OK, well, these
are the three or four things
that we can do to solve that.
But like everything, there's
a knock-on effect that
will go on if you change that.
So you need to understand
what each thing will do
and how it'll change the
behavior of the car and the way
that you're driving it so
that you choose the thing that
will improve the most what
your problem is but take away
the least amount somewhere else.
So having an understanding
of the broad scope
of the engineering side
of the car is important.
But in terms of the actual
engineering decisions,
there's people with Master's
degrees in vehicle dynamics
and engineering that are
probably more qualified.
But to have a full
global understanding,
at least the basics,
is very important.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks again
to all of you for coming.
It's really great to be in
the presence of greatness.
My question is about
the process of mastery.
personal growth and becoming
better at what you do.
We, the public, get a lot of
focus on the best in any field.
The best showmen in
wrestling or the best race
finishers in racing.
I'm curious to know about,
what does it take to get there?
What was it like not being the
greatest wrestler of all time
and working your
way towards that?
Is it a focus on showmanship,
are there major difficulties
along the way?
RIC FLAIR: Well, that's easy.
I actually talk
about this a lot when
I'm doing some
motivational speaking.
First of all, you have
to love what you do.
And you have to believe
in yourself if you
want to sell the character.
For me, like I said earlier,
anything I said on TV,
I was actually doing it.
Probably not the best
advice for anybody
because we're doing
different things,
but work ethic, belief in
yourself, self-confidence
is huge.
I'm sure it is for these guys.
You have to have
tremendous self-confidence.
But work ethic and the
time they put into it.
We can sit up here and make
light of things and all that,
but these guys are getting
ready for something that's huge
and they're driving
that car, like I said,
at 230 miles an hour.
And that's something
I can't even fathom,
and I'm not making light of it.
It's just something I don't
even want to go into--
they have a test car where
they'll take you on it.
I didn't want to do it.
Don't make a joke
about that to anybody.
But--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: You
already signed up.
I just did it online.
RIC FLAIR: It's just
work ethic, dedication,
and belief in whatever
you're trying to achieve.
You have to really
like it and want it.
Even at 25 years
of age, Conor had
to want to do this
for a long time.
And this is his third race.
Is that right?
CONOR DALY: Fourth one, yeah.
RIC FLAIR: Fourth at Indy?
Yeah.
So I mean it's huge.
That's my take on it.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
I would say I'm definitely
no master of motor sport
or anywhere near that yet.
But it does take a lot of--
I started when I was 10 and I,
from basically age 10 to 14,
you realize--
racing go karts, only go karts.
But it's like,
traveling every weekend,
doing a lot of different stuff.
My dad raced, as well,
so he knew what it took.
And it took everything.
It takes your entire life.
I missed 70 days of school
a year in high school.
And I showed up to my
high school graduation
and people had no idea that
I still went to the school.
But it's just--
I didn't-- I never
went to a prom,
didn't go to any of that stuff.
All I cared about was racing
and my dad, every week made,
sure to tell me,
are you sure you
want to do this
because this will
take every part of your life?
And it's true.
I graduated high school,
moved to London when I was 18.
I lived with a friend
of mine's stepdad.
I didn't have
friends over there.
All it was was race
track, back home.
Simulator, race
track all the time.
And that was through
all my college years.
I got back to America at
age 21, 22, or 22, really.
Yeah.
It just takes everything.
There's a lot-- I
missed out on college.
I don't know what that's like.
I see that, from the
internet, it looks cool.
But I mean, I guess it's one
of those things that people--
RIC FLAIR: I was
there for a year.
CONOR DALY: Was it fun?
RIC FLAIR: I don't remember.
[LAUGHTER]
CONOR DALY: See?
Yeah, well you have
to give up a lot.
RIC FLAIR: I was having fun.
CONOR DALY: Exactly.
RIC FLAIR: Had a hard time
finding where the class was.
But I was there.
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
That's the thing.
How much are you willing to
give up to succeed at something?
And that's, I think,
when it comes down to it,
how much time are you willing to
dedicate to this goal of being
a paid racing driver?
Which was something that isn't
really that common these days.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MIKE ABRAMS: We
probably have time
for two more quick questions.
AUDIENCE: So I know that
regulations are incredibly
important to your sport because,
unlike say, most other sports,
which are just constrained
by the performance
potential of the
human body, there's
essentially no limit whatsoever
on what technology can achieve.
So I was wondering if you were
the regulatory board, just
the two of you, and you were
able to set new standards
and new changes and
regulations for future years,
what would you change and why?
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
For me, it would
be about improving
the racing product.
And the way to do that is,
because these cars generate
so much downforce,
the problem with that
is when you're
following another car
and you don't have all of the
air being completely attached
as you drive through it, there's
a pretty big knock-on effect
to the following car.
Because all of the
aero is, obviously,
about low and high pressure
sensitivities and areas
and how the air
goes over the wings
and then reattaches,
creating pressure.
So there's a huge
amount of downforce
that comes from
the top of the car
and not so much that
comes from the bottom.
And the reasons for
that is because of fear
of cars going too quickly.
Because there was a period
of time in motor sports
where there was blown diffusers
and there was actually
fans underneath the cars that
were sucking the cars down
and the speeds were just getting
a little bit out of control.
But because safety
has developed so far
from when this existed
in the mid to late '90s,
there's less of a need
to reduce the speeds
as much as they have now.
And so for me, it would
be all about putting
much of the downforce
and aerodynamic potential
on the bottom of the car
so that when you're driving
you're not affected by the car
in front, which means better
racing, more entertainment,
and something for the fans
to get even more excited about.
And actually, with all credit
to the rising IndyCar series,
they are doing that,
and next year cars
are doing exactly
what I just explained
with the new
aerodynamic packages
and it's very exciting
to be a part of.
And IndyCar is one of
the few championships
I feel is really on the cutting
edge of improving the racing
product and having a
forward-thinking vision of what
they want the sport to be,
instead of solely being
in a reactionary position like
other racing championships.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, I think this--
I mean, that's true.
Downforce from the floor will
improve the racing, for sure,
on short ovals for us.
I think a lot more
horsepower will be awesome.
I mean, race cars,
mid-'90s, 1,000 horsepower.
We only have 650,
700 on a good day.
And you know, that's a lot.
MIKE ABRAMS: That's
because you drive a Chevy.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, I know.
I was fixing to say.
We have 650, they have 700.
But it's one of those things
that I think we need more--
I know everyone loves eco
fuels and all that stuff,
but like I would
really like to see
like another V12 engine blowing
your ears off and laying
tire tracks out of every
corner with 1,200 horse--
I mean, I think that
would be awesome.
MIKE ABRAMS: [INAUDIBLE].
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
Because I mean-- yeah,
2.2 liter V6 engines
aren't that exciting
to me, in all honesty.
I hope-- I think we're
on the way to also being
eco-ish, but improving
horsepower, as well.
So hopefully--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Eco-ish,
the new gold standard of--
CONOR DALY: Yeah, they're
going to paint it green
and then say--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: So
I'm from California
and he's from Indiana,
if you didn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
CONOR DALY: Yeah, sorry.
More horsepower, more floor
downforce, and let's go.
That's all we need.
MIKE ABRAMS: Got time
for one quick question.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
Quick one.
So I'm a big motorcycle guy.
I'm from Atlanta, so there's
a lot more open space.
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
Atlanta, check it out.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I get super excited.
I feel like a general
badass when I'm going, like,
130 miles an hour, right?
How do you guys translate going
from miles an hour on race day
to driving around, putzing
at 50 miles an hour,
and not getting
speeding tickets?
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Well, my Honda
Pilot only does, like, 80,
so I don't have a problem.
It does 0 to 60 in five minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
It's great, though.
Because it drives
itself, which is awesome.
It's like Tesla and Honda
pilots which do that.
Other than that, it's such a
different environment that--
he actually drives
slower than I do.
CONOR DALY: Yeah, I do.
But I hate the road.
I just hate the general
public on the road.
It's just so infuriating.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: But when I have
to go on a road trip with him,
I have to add like--
I normally subtract 25, 30
minutes from Google Maps.
CONOR DALY: I'm a rule follower.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: His is
exactly what the Google
Maps says it's going to be.
CONOR DALY: No, that's not true.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: And
you're just like, well.
CONOR DALY: Not true at all.
But I am a rule follower.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: Have you
ever gotten a speeding ticket?
CONOR DALY: Yeah.
Five.
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
I've gotten none.
CONOR DALY: Six of them.
ALEXANDER ROSSI: So maybe
you should start speeding.
CONOR DALY: How does that work?
Jeez.
Driving on the road,
very different,
obviously, unless you're
in some form of super car,
which we do not own,
either of us, yet.
I have big plans in my
life, guys, don't worry.
But if I was driving a
Lamborghini everyday, or--
man, I don't know
about the laws.
They would be-- yeah.
It's tough.
Either way, I just
hate driving slow.
My foot is just always annoyed.
Wouldn't you agree?
You just--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: No.
CONOR DALY: Like, we
can't go 60 miles an hour.
That's not even a thing.
I have never gone
60 miles an hour,
I don't think, ever, on a road
that has a 55 mile an hour
speed limit.
Have you?
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
What are you saying?
CONOR DALY: If it's 55--
ALEXANDER ROSSI:
In a school zone,
you should definitely
not be doing 60.
CONOR DALY: No,
no, of course not.
48.
[LAUGHTER]
All I'm saying is speed
limit plus 30 is normal,
I think unless there
are children around.
What do you think?
How do you drive, Ric?
RIC FLAIR: Actually,
I'm much better.
I got put in jail
one time because I
had 86 moving violations
over a five-year period.
CONOR DALY: That's a lot.
RIC FLAIR: And I went--
ALEXANDER ROSSI: 86?
RIC FLAIR: Yeah.
86.
Well, because in
the old days, prior
to the reciprocal agreement
with states, in South Carolina,
as an example, I'd
get four tickets
driving on the Charleston.
All you did was give $20,
turn it over, throw it,
and I keep going.
And you could drink
back then in a car.
CONOR DALY: Oh, jeez.
RIC FLAIR: It's changed a lot.
But anyway, I finally got
busted because I got two
going 80 in one day
in North Carolina
and I had to go to court.
And the judge sentenced
me to 30 days,
called me a habitual speeder.
I went downstairs for
about an hour, man,
and I didn't like that.
Locked up for the night, right?
But then I went to Superior
Court and the guy laughed at it
and fined me $25.
But it slowed me down.
I never thought
of it, but, hell,
I had three drivers licenses--
Minnesota, Florida,
and North Carolina.
Just every time one of went
down, pulled out the other one.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, I knew a lot about driving.
CONOR DALY: That's
why he's a hero.
RIC FLAIR: But I've
slowed down now.
Trust me.
I certainly don't
drink and drive.
I'm going to go--
that's the only thing I
haven't done wrong.
No DUIs.
That's not going to change.
If I have a beer, I get a ride.
That's all I need.
That would be all over Google.
Ric Flair, DUI.
No, thank you.
MIKE ABRAMS: Well, gentlemen,
thank you for being here.
The Indianapolis 500 will
air on ABC on Sunday, May 28,
at noon eastern.
The car will be here for
about the next half hour
if you want to take
pictures with it.
You cannot get in it.
And please don't sit on it.
But you can take
pictures around it.
Thanks, guys.
CONOR DALY: Thank you, guys.
RIC FLAIR: Thank you.
CONOR DALY: I appreciate it.
RIC FLAIR: Thanks
for all the respect.
[APPLAUSE]